[Music]
Danny Danny you okay it's just a bad
memory to the past
helps on a war is brewing
this is my city now it's my duty to
protect him
hi and I'm not backing down
[Music]
she won't put this war to rest and I'll
find a way
hey everybody its charlie they released
another Iron Fist season 2 promo
this one mostly focusing on the immortal
weapons in the capital cities of heaven
in the tournament that they fight but
mostly they're just hyping up Danny Rand
versus Davos the steel serpent so let's
break it down if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the Marvel videos there's a new round of
that infinity war blu-ray giveaway - all
you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video I'll name a new winner at the end
of this the big thing that's going on is
at Comic Con they release this promo
image and they actually change their
Twitter profile their social profiles to
this there were a lot of news outlets
that we're missing this - just being
Iron Fist new symbol but that's not iron
fists new symbol that's Davos is simple
they just want to let you know that
they're doing full-blown steel serpent
as this trailer applies Danny has the
flash backs to them just beating the
life out of each other in there wearing
versions of the comic book costume with
the special masks this is meant to be a
reference to the white costume if you
remember at the end of defenders he was
wearing the green tracksuit which seems
like it's gonna be their version of the
green comic book suit so I don't know if
we'll see him wearing the mask in
present-day with the green tracksuit for
a full blown comic book costume or if
we're just gonna see him in the green
tracksuit by the end of the season but
the thing about Davos is symbol is that
it doesn't get the wings until he
becomes one of the immortal weapons of
the other capital cities of heaven when
he gets the power he takes the name
steel Phoenix and his symbol gets the
wings on it so if he's gonna be steel
Phoenix he may have or he may become one
of the immortal weapons of the other
capital cities of heaven during season
two but that feels like something they
might leave for the end of the season
like Danny eventually defeats him he
doesn't take his power but he gets the
power from one of the other capital
cities of heaven the trailers don't give
away a whole lot of the story the second
trailer that I attached to that is
really just him defending the city
because Matt isn't around they still
think that daredevil is dead even though
we know better they've already finished
filming season 3 Vincent D'Onofrio has
been promoting his return as Wilson Fisk
on his Twitter profile so who knows what
they're gonna do with that they didn't
bring anything to Comic Con I think
because they still want people to
pretend like Matt is dead like all the
defenders still think that he's gone so
even though they finish
filming daredevil season three before
they finished filming iron fist season
two I guess it has something to do with
the conflict that's building up and they
want Danny to be more of a protector to
the city until Matt comes back they want
the other defenders to feel like they
have to step up and no spoilers for the
end of Luke Cage I've already done a
video about that but that gives you a
good idea for where Iron Fist character
is right now they just kind of
completely recalibrated him pretended
like that first season never happened
albeit for a little bit of plot points
to pick up where Davos left off with
Madame crane because as far as we know
they entered into a contract he was
going to kill Danny Rand and steal his
power is iron fist but then a building
fell on madam Gauss
so if she's not dead we have no idea but
unless you see a body you can't confirm
death they just want us to think that
she's gone I think all the defenders did
was get rid of the hand as an antagonist
so it seems like what they're doing with
iron fist is moving more into the
capital cities of heaven in the immortal
weapons storyline from the comics if
you're not a big Matt Fraction fan he
wrote a really awesome run where they
just dealt with the tournament between
the seven different capital cities of
heaven but like you look at the star
here there are eight points because
there is a secret eight capital city of
heaven that's this hellish nightmare
scape that they dug to underground in
the comics which is why when the hand
was digging underground to that dragon
graveyard I was like maybe that's them
teasing the eighth capital city of
heaven but we have no idea how they're
gonna invoke that mythology they keep
things so real-world that I'm not
expecting them to get true crazy with
this iron fist mythology
he's the natural-born son of Lake Heung
the Thunderer who's this person right
here the person that trained Danny ran
to fight and become iron fist this
person here is probably whitey who's the
leader of Kunlun in the comics each
capital city has their own leader and
their own immortal weapon to defend it
in the tournament that determines their
place in the celestial clock so when
Kunlun disappeared at the end of iron
fist season one it sounded like Danny
wasn't there to fight and maybe a
tournament in the celestial clock
shifted because Kunlun lost because
their defender wasn't there so now
they're cut off from the mortal plane so
it sounds like Danny is going to have to
find a way to get that back
or win out against someone else in the
tournament like Davos like it says that
they're coming for Danny I don't know
how deep they're gonna get into that
either but part of the mission will be
in finding out what happened to Conlon
if it's going to be some different twist
from the comics but the whole thing that
they're hyping up here is you're Stanny
versus Davos in the idea of the
tournament so I just expect them to
invoke that in some way the other really
big thing to note here too that you
don't get from just watching this
obviously the choreography looks better
but they hired a different showrunner
that put a renewed focus on the fight
choreography and they hired the fight
choreographer from Black Panther so
it'll be interesting to see if some of
the fights feel a little bit like black
panther but really big easter egg from
the comics black panther actually
studied the martial arts that they learn
in Conlan it's a derivative of kung fu
but you have to imagine that it's like
the best kung fu that you could possibly
learn so with just another reason why
black panther is such a badass is
because he has all this vibranium Tech
he has the heart-shaped herb which
enhances his abilities but he's also
trained from the finest martial arts
teachers in the universe which are in
Conlan so I'm not expecting any big
Black Panther Easter eggs in the series
or anything like that it's just a really
cool detail about his character in the
comics there's really nowhere to go for
this series but up so anything it all
would be an improvement so I'm very
optimistic that it will definitely be
better than season 1 but we'll see how
Dany during Iron Fist Season 2 compares
to Danny
during Power Man Iron Fist team up
during Luke Cage season 2
like six pack killer bees Zack
hopefully they bring back some of that
Wu Tang iron fist
Wu Tang iron fist currently the best
version of iron fist so congratulations
to the latest giveaway winner comic DJ
please email me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details there's a whole bunch of
infinity war bonus features dropping so
I'll do videos for that tomorrow click
here to learn about how Marvel is
getting all the x-men and the Fantastic
Four characters back and click here to
re-watch that Iron Fist Power Man
team-up scene from Luke Cage thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you